apex of all the committees and i've been
appointed to ways and means
thank you very much glad to be here
uh john jan jannigan did i say that
correct
it's um actually and ian
is uh like ian so jenigian
and um i'm uh starting my third term
my first two terms i was on public works
and highways
and um i'm very pleased to join ways and
means and
hope that i can help out and
and um my background wise i have a
bachelor's degree in chemistry
and a master's degree in computer
science um spent about 25 years in the
computer
software industry uh holding various
positions from computer programmer
to director of engineering uh more
recently i've been
out of out of tech and and um i'm a real
estate broker
and uh my wife and i properly manage our
own properties
so uh have a very varied bit of
experience and hope to um
be effective on ways and means
well thank you john uh before we go on
you mentioned your experience with
computer engineering
and what i'd like to know is
anybody that's on the committee that
could help us out
in uh operating these so-called
zoom meetings or hybrid meetings
if you would step forward and let myself
or again know
you will be a health because sometimes
things get pretty
challenging and we need all the help we
can to make sure that everything
goes smoothly so next would be
marshall news
thank you mr chairman good morning uh
colleagues i'm hershel nunes and i live
in pelham new hampshire i've been in new
hampshire for about 20 years i moved
here from texas from houston texas um
i've worked in um in hr systems
implementing hr systems for about 25
years
i'm now retired this is my second term i
also serve on the labor committee i'm
one of those two committee people
this this time so nice to meet everyone
thank you ken baxter
i thank you mr chairman and hello uh
colleagues i'm really looking forward to
serving with all of you i'm a freshman
representative
from seabrook and hampton falls which is
district rockingham 20.
i'm a small business owner i only manage
a six
unit residential business so i'm in
real estate um as same as john and then
i also
run a non-profit that created second
chances which helped fund
people struggling with addiction to get
them into treatment programs so
again i'm really looking forward to
serving with all of you
thank you walters uh spellsbury
good morning everybody i'm
living in charlestown over at the
connecticut river valley
i grew up initially on long island went
to college in maine
discovered the beauty of northern new
england at bowdoin
i earned a law degree in seattle at
university of washington
and later in the middle of my career in
mba at columbia in new york
um i've been hit there heather and young
living in working in seattle washington
dc
uh new jersey the netherlands
connecticut and came here 13 years ago
i'm retired and work actively in the
community
uh 13 years with the scout troop aida
scoutmaster just
left as chairman planning board chairman
finance committee
uh previously heritage commission so
it's time for me to come to the state
house and i
appreciate being here with you all
another scouter i just see you
pause to do it good morning
i'm a freshman state rep from northwood
i also serve on the northwood budget
committee
i've been in northwood for approximately
20 years my mother was born here
i grew up in massachusetts and was
educated in massachusetts i have a
bs in mechanical engineering i spent
35 years working for a general electric
company in linmass
operating and designing the jet engine
test facilities
in lynn i look forward to uh working
with the committee on on matters going
forward
currently retired
thank you susan elmy
hi i'm susan elmi i'm from lebanon new
hampshire
um i have been working
for i realized that i'm halfway through
a 50-year career
i mean no i'm i'm
i'm i've finished a 50-year career now
in two pieces that were equal to each
other
25 years in uh
on africa and latin america
on basically working as a
socio-economist
that's something that um i evolved for
myself it is a practicing
uh renaissance social scientist but
i also have worked with agronomy i've
worked
spent a lot of time in very muddy fields
and
in countries with all kinds of political
systems
and all kinds of economic chaos or or
hope going on uh and
i i then ran into medical problems that
made it difficult on to continue
impossible to continue
in uh third world cities uh
and came home and
to be near my parents and uh fell
into the legislature uh within a year
so um i have been 25 years now
in the new hampshire legislature
i came in at the same time as your chair
our chair
and on we joined the finance committee
together
12 terms ago and moved on
were put on the division that
had to deal suddenly with the claremont
education funding problem uh
and which qualified us as tax experts
by the time that was over and uh we
moved together to ways and means
on 11 terms ago
and so i'm starting my 13th term
and i have always
believed that on
the best we can do for an economy
is for to enable as many people as
possible
to be creative about solutions to goals
that are
developed by the the
total community and
[Music]
we've been doing that in our committee
for quite a while
on we are in a very strange economic
time
it's going to be really difficult and i
am so glad
that represent a major is chair this
term instead of me i took us through the
great recession
thank you thank you susan
as you can tell susan and i've been
together for a long time
okay next would be dick ames you know
richard ames was the vice chair
and says in this chat it means
thank you so
let's see i've been on the ways and
means committee for
eight years this is my ninth year and um
that's been a great experience two
terrific leaders
representative major and representative
army through those
years and uh before that
going way back i received my i
earned my law degree in the late 60s
then proceeded into practice
after a stint in the peace corps
and you could sort of roughly divide my
career before i retired in 2001
into two parts one first part was in the
public sector second part of the private
sector
in the public sector i served as general
counsel for a number of
state agencies and in the private sector
i had my own
law office and primarily worked in the
field of disabilities particularly
mental disabilities and
and so that was that was a good period
of time
came to new hampshire in 2001
and uh i've enjoyed myself ever since
so i guess that's enough thank you
thank you dick tom southward
good morning hi i'm tom southworth from
dover new hampshire
um this is my fourth term in the house
and my fourth term on ways and means
which i have really enjoyed
my background is in public education i
was a reading teacher
school counselor and finally
administrator
i did quite a bit with budgets and data
analysis
and writing federal grants in dover i'm
also a selectman
and on a non-profit board i've lived
mainly in the norwich vermont hanover
area when i was younger
and now the seacoast area so i've kind
of you know i've had
had the best of both worlds so to speak
thanks
thank you tom dennis malloy
he was the past clerk of the committee
yeah thank you uh representative major
and i i i really enjoyed that work and
uh
um representative bernstein if there's
anything you
need or can help you with or work
through that be happy to
help you if you so choose
uh i my wife and i moved here from iowa
in 2001
born and raised in iowa
bachelor's degree from co college and
cedar rapids master's degree
from iowa state university and
journalism mass communication i
was the chief development officer at
iowa public television
for 15 years moved here to be the
chief development officer at new
hampshire public television for 10 years
that's a job where we raise the private
money the non-public
uh non-public money for uh these
operations
multi-million dollar operations and i
was responsible for all the
private funding there uh here
in new hampshire i'm on now i'm on the
board of trustees of the granite state y
and i'm the
chair of the advisory board of the
seacoast ymca
and also a graduate of leadership in
hampshire
this is my fourth term
and my third term on ways and means
my first term was on municipal and
county government
when i was elected first to the house
from barrington
for a term and then
for one term and then we moved to
greenland my wife and i moved to
greenland to be closer to her business
in portsmouth
uh and uh i ran in greenland here
in 2016.
um and that's what i've been doing uh
since then um
that's the uh that's that's my story
and uh enjoy both municipal and county
government and
ways and means this has been my role was
to project revenues and raise revenues
for
both of these uh public television
networks
so it's a very comfortable place for me
to be thank you for your
leadership representative majors and
representative almi
it's been terrific thank you dennis
uh thomas chamber
thank you mr chairman and that tie is
quite bright
okay uh my name is tom shamford
i represent the towns of wilmington
sutton near new london
i'm a retired teacher
after retirement one got my jd in
massachusetts
i also serve on the select board of
and on the municipal budget committee
for the kearsarge regional school
district
thank you very much and if anybody is my
third term
on ways and means thank you thank you
tom
next would be edith tucker
yeah yes i'm live in randolph new
hampshire in the north country
right on route 2 that goes between
gorham and lancaster i've been a
reporter
i still do some reporting i report on
what happens in gorham which i don't
represent
i represent whitefield carroll which is
twin mountain and
redwoods uh jefferson and randolph
so i have two grand hotels in my
district
uh which is sort of one end of the
economic spectrum
and a lot of despair too up here
i've served on school boards in
massachusetts
and a member of leadership new hampshire
class
and enjoy my time in randolph
where my husband and i uh moved
a little over 25 years ago where
my extended family spends time in the
summer
and means has been a terrific experience
this is my
third term i'm going into and what's
been
really gratifying and ways and means is
that
there's a tremendous effort to be able
to reach consensus
on factual matters and
i think it gives our community a
tremendous strength
in the house itself naturally on
things that our partisan people are
partisan
but on seeking the facts
there is an agreement that will work
together
and i i think it's really a fabulous
committee to be on
for that reason i don't bring as many
financial uh
qualifications as many on the committee
but
this outstanding contribution the
committee makes
to the legislature is very important to
me thank you
thank you edith next is janine
gramaro
you have to unmute yourself
sorry about that thank you norm um
this is my second term and i served on
ways and me
means my first term i'm a small business
owner with my husband here in swansea
lived here the majority of my life
um i've previously
served here in town
on the school district budget committee
uh the local library as treasurer and
trustee
for 10 years and i was the town
treasurer
um in for a year and a half until i got
this job and
the time constraints didn't work um
[Music]
i enjoyed this committee a lot there was
a big learning curve but
i'm looking forward to this term with
you all thank you
thank you janine says uh tom longman
and it's jenny by the way norm not
janine
thank you for jennifer well you're gonna
have to keep correcting me because i
really screwed names up and i apologize
ahead of time
okay tom
tom long time which tom
i'm here i'm here now sorry it was a
double muted um it's good to be with you
all this morning
um representative tom lachman from
hampton this is my second term in the
house
second term on ways and memes very
pleased to see
my returning colleagues and looking
forward to working with you all again
and looking forward to meeting getting
to know
some of the new members of the committee
and just to echo something that
representative tucker said i found
my time on this committee to be among
the least partisan
experiences in politics and i
enjoy that enjoy the collaboration and
the thoughtfulness that goes into the
work we do
i am an environmental health and safety
executive for
a top government contractor we do a lot
of work for the department of defense
intelligence agencies and department of
energy
i also do a little bit of teaching
part-time
for harvard university school of public
health on the subjects of performance
measurement
and analytics so i think my interest in
data
and analysis uh served me well here and
um again just looking forward to working
with you all because this is a
consequential time
for the state of new hampshire and glad
we have
a lot of good heads in the room to solve
problems
thank you thank you tom
next is a mata
yeah i will no worries it happens all
the time
so um hi all my name is amanda gorg
it rhymes as my mom says with morg
or if you're a star wars fan it rhymes
with porg
so just drop the extra vowels and you'll
probably figure it out
um i live in lee so i represent lee
and barrington this is my third
term last year i was the chair of
environment and agriculture i
own my own marketing meetings and events
company
i'm also a real estate agent which seems
to be a common theme in this group which
is awesome
i also have an mba i love budgeting and
numbers
so i'm very happy to be with all of you
uh this term
thank you amanda next is
mary haken
yes hi everyone representative mary
hacken phillips here
i also have a difficult last name um the
first last name is
hackin like a computer hack that's
helpful
i am our first um incoming you know
first year
freshman legislator and i am excited to
be joining your ways and means committee
i'm a native michigander i have a
ba and a m.a in political science as
well as a
jd i am a practicing real estate and
business law attorney in concord
before my legal career i have a
background
as an executive assistant in both
finance and banking
i currently serve on the hanover finance
committee
and i'm looking forward to working with
all of you
thank you mary and uh last
is james murphy good morning all my name
is jim murphy i'm up here in hanover
uh with uh mary i also am a
freshman rep in the house serving
hanover in
line um i'm a native granite stater i've
lived
in hanover for over 40 years
and have lived in the state of new
hampshire for well over 50 years some of
you may remember
when it was new england telephone that's
my dad that was my dad's company when he
got out of the navy
and every time he got a promotion we got
a move so i've lived in manchester twice
conquered once portsmouth or hampton
once and then berlin for about three
years
um i then left uh
the granite state to go to college in
central mass
i got my medical degree in dc
and then have practiced orthopedic
surgery for the past 40 years having
retired about a year ago
i worked both at dartmouth hitchcock for
about 30 years and at new london
hospital
as a chief medical officer for
additional nine or ten years
i retired a year ago this is my freshman
year in the house and i'm looking
forward to working with everybody in
ways and means
we'll hopefully enjoy the time when we
can get together
and do the work of this thing so thank
you
thank you james isn't this great look at
the diverse
amount of talent that we have here
spread all over
and i'm looking forward to working with
everybody now about myself
i've um a new hampshire
born raised person i lived in new
hampshire all my life
except for the time i spent in the
military
i have a master's science
a bachelor of science in electrical
engineering i work for
the bell system spent about 12 years
with
as a designer for bell laboratories 12
years as a
as a manufacturing engineer for western
electric and 12 years as a
engineering manager for atm i've retired
and i get my my attention from lewiston
which has been bought out by another
company that's been bought out by
another company
so let's still consider myself a bell
system person
i spent about 50 years
in addition to that either as a
selectmen
budget committee board of adjustments
or moderating staff
or as a elected state rep
and i've enjoyed them all and
like as susan told you we both came in
at the same time
13 times ago and i spent most of my time
in boys and men's
and susan and i we rotate all the time
whenever the democrats are in the
majority she
chairs and republicans are in a majority
high chair
but we work with each other you know we
have different
political beliefs and we we stay with
those beliefs
but we can still work with each other we
always try to find
common ground because to be an effective
legislator you have to know how to
communicate negotiate and compromise
you can't do that you really shouldn't
be here but there's so many
that are in the legislature that has not
learned that
so i hope we all continue this
because we were the only committee
that met remotely at unh
i got a vote that was like what 315
to five when we met
at unh on our revenue estimates
everything else is a complete chaos
battle everything i mean this strictly
political down the line
but as it's been said
as jesus has said we deal on facts and
we try to stay with those facts
and throughout the committee
we do the revenue estimates
i will make sure that each and every one
of you participate
because if you don't participate you
don't learn anything you just sit there
and listen
so you'll see me okay mary
what do you think where is this going to
go
and there is no such thing as a
i know i'm rambling on there's no such
thing as a dumb question
there's a question bring it out because
somebody else probably wanted to say it
too
but thank god you said it all right i
think we need to get into the program
now
we were given an organization uh
shoot the committee purpose and all that
and i'll just quickly run down this
the committee purpose is to examine and
consider the state of the treasury
also to consider and report on all bills
and resolutions
relating to money by state taxes
fees or other methods of raising state
funds
and other matters referring to it
and report to the house in the form of
house resolution
and estimates of state revenues
so we have two major jobs
there are other committees normally just
contend with bills we have to contend
with the bills that are before us
as well as revenue estimates
the other day as i looked and we had 10
bills
i looked this morning now we have 21
days
and look later on this week we'll
probably do more than that
and we have to determine on these bills
which are the early
bills and which of the late bills and
those early bills we don't have much
time
to get them out the early bills i
believe have to be out
and like the 18th
the first thing we need to do is to do
the revenue estimates
none of us can do the revenue estimates
not even
the people who have been pretty long
time
until we re-educate ourselves
so as you know in the calendar we have a
hybrid arrangement
scheduled for next week it's called an
economic update
on that economic update the first day on
the 19th
we'll be bringing in seven different
type of economies
or experts relative to
the process and the next day there will
be six or seven
more presenters and these presenters
will all be
presenting virtually and we're scheduled
to meet
in the reps hall but we may change that
because of what's going on right now we
may
end up going completely virtual
and i'll get into more of the schedule
later
but after we spend next week
with the economy the following week
we'll spend a number of days with agency
heads
the agency has that are responsible for
different revenues we have new hampshire
is unique
you're a state that doesn't have we're
the only state that doesn't have a
broad-based tax
we don't have a base income tax and
broadband
sales tax we pay for our budget
what i call a portfolio of taxes and
fees
business taxes
and a whole lot of other things
and these taxes and fees
are all controlled administration with
them is controlled by
various agencies we'll bring in these
agency heads
and they'll tell us
what is the status of
say the rooms and meals tax what's the
status
of the liquor
what's the status of tobacco
and we'll spend a few days
full days doing that
because it will take us all that amount
of time to get ready
to generate our revenue estimates so
that's the education process
part of it i talked to the
chairman of the finance committee ken
weiler
they're going to be getting the
governor's
budget on the 15th of february so we
need to have
our revenues to the house
around that same time we talked 15th of
february from now there's not much time
to do that
and then also the i think it's
the following week you need to get the
second the bills that go into the second
committee out
so we're gonna have to be dealing with
second committee bills while we're going
with revenue estimates
so we've got a lot of work ahead of us
but we'll do it
so those are our two main areas
now the rules of the committee we have
a committee meeting and it says eight
o'clock or nine o'clock
that means eight o'clock and then five
it's not
two or three minutes late
first thing is it's impolite
to waste somebody's time that's there
early
because you decide for some maybe it
isn't
but don't come late if you're gonna be
late
give me a call you're not going to show
up with him in the fall
so we know that you can get started with
that
knowledge
now normally when we have public
hearings
there's no food or drink during the
public hand
we're operating under emergency artists
so it's extremely difficult to have
public hearings the way he had before
they're going to be
zoom type or hybrid type public hearings
so we're going to have to
work our way through this process
it's a new process for all of us
last year we were hit with this
process the
last day we had regular legislative
meetings was the 12th of march
since then the legislative office
building has been closed
i went to the legislative office
building yesterday
the first time since march 12th
because my office was moving i had to
make sure this stuff was
all ready to remove
we're still not going to be able to get
back into our regular offices
what they're doing is they're going to
have
double rows so that we can maintain the
six foot distance
they still have the face mask
and yesterday they just came in they
were delivered the air purifiers they're
going to have these
gigantic air purifiers to these double
rooms
they can only make four double rooms per
floor
so four double rooms before you're
talking about
eight committees can be meeting
at once so rather than meeting normally
tuesday wednesday and thursday some
communities are gonna have to
make monday thursday monday
et cetera so monday till friday
we've got to be prepared we don't know
what those dates are yet
because things haven't been worked out
yet so
the bills that that this came in the 21
bills
i'm not sure how many of those are going
to be early bills and how many
[Music]
the second committee bills are due the
18th of february
i want to have the revenues out
on the 16th of february
we don't have much time so we have a lot
to do
next week is the 19th and 20th
where we're going to have the economic
update
the following week is going to have the
agency heads come in
in the following two weeks we're going
to
have work sessions
where we debate get our questions
answered
i have a phone line ignore it
i'm only hoping that the early bills
that we have
there's only just a few of them and the
both of them
could become could come in later
and the rest of the bills
uh will be due
the 25th
of march so that gives a lot a lot more
time the 25th of march
is only 10 weeks away
so if we end up with 40 bills
and every bill has to have a public
hearing and usually
after public hearing there's a lot of
questions if there's a lot of questions
then we'll put then we need to sign
subcommittees
usually we run maybe about four
and then the subcommittee chair uh
signing subtle committee chairs and i
try to balance it out
and then there'll be uh
by them have proponents and opponents
on the subcommittee so that
both sides of the issue can be debated
and then after the sub committee meet
they can also
bring in people to ask questions
they can act like a regular committee
and then they
they also have to have their hearings
notice there's a 24-hour notice versus
the very little committee needs to be
noticed a week ahead of time
then when the subcommittee finishes
their work
you get together as a full committee
again and then
we exact hopefully everybody can take
part in that exactly
you know that you're not going to be
there without that
minority leader which would be
citizen or myself as a majority
leader for the uh republicans you know
so that we can get a replacement so we
have
a low compliment the republican
democrats would be able
to vote on this executive committee
now you can read through the sheets that
i
sent you to karen or
jen all the things that
we expect from committee members
one of the things is that you're a
sponsor or co-sponsor of a bill
before the committee this
sponsor
cannot or and the co-sponsor cannot ask
questions of the person that's
testifying
they have to sit back to the people
who are there to observe the committees
and then they they can be they can
testify themselves
i notice i put a lot of items there but
they're all
important
when we do
vote on the bill an exec session
there's two types of calendars you can
go on you can go on the regular calendar
or you can go on the consent calendar
the consent calendar means that it's a
bill that usually comes out of committee
during the anonymous vote
if it's a unanimous vote and it
doesn't do with raising revenues
and you can vote to go on the consent
calendar
and all the consent calendars when they
go to the full house
will be voted on by one vote
unless some of them have been taken off
now one person in the committee objects
to having it on consent and they want
to go in the regular calendar so it can
be debated
then that's what it would be it will not
be any consent
but you'll learn these things as you go
through the process
the subcommittees
you'll all have an opportunity to sign
up for whatsapp community that you want
to do
i just want to make sure it's balanced
though
and if you're not assigned to a
subcommittee and sub community
holds a hearing you can still go to that
and participate
um there's one other thing
next week it's scheduled to hold the
meeting
and reps hall of the joint
senate and house members
and unless individual members want to
participate remotely
if that happens
you get into rep paul you can only do it
two ways
one is into the state house
from park state on the side entrance
will provide the security people the
names of the committee members
so that when you go in the name will be
there and they'll check the temperature
and that so allow you to come in
the other way is to go into the
legislative office building and
you'll be checked by the yard there and
then you go through the tunnel
over into the state house
but let me kind of warn you right now
i got a call this morning that there's a
possibility that
uh you may not be meeting reptile
next week um because
of the threat the
various capitals state capitals in the
united states
and we're just notified this morning the
legislative budget office
will not be
in the state house next week because of
that threat
when i get off this meeting with
today i will be contacting the speaker
and finding out what the situation is
because they may
completely close the state house down
and we'll have to do this we're not
going to stop this meeting and then i
could do it completely
virtual as i hear now there's a number
of
uh committee members from both the
senate
and the house that will be
[Music]
participating virtually i think is at
least nine right now
i don't have a problem doing that
because
all the presenters were going to be
presenting directly anyway
and then you know and all the
outside members that were going to be
listening
[Music]
be prepared that we'll be doing this
virtually
and we'll let you know
i that i've talked a bit just
do you have any questions between
uh susan and myself we may be able to
answer them
and major um representative almy has her
hand up and also representative gomarlo
representative
thank you on you have been talking about
an
organization sheet which is what we hand
out when we're there
in person did that get sent to us
because i didn't get one
uh that was sent to everybody as part of
the invitation
right again yes that's right but
i could send it out again represent how
me thank you
yeah i did not notice that at all i'm
sorry
it's a three-page information sheet and
i assume
if you got it would you raise your hand
okay so mostly everybody received this
about half looks like
well um both of them
yes fantasy
and there's a lot there
i i can go through every every single
line right now
but and basically it's the rules of the
operation of the committee under the new
chair
it's the same rules that we've been
operating under for
quite a while
one of the most important things is
especially for the new people
when somebody's up there testifying and
you
completely disagree with them
you don't disagree with them from the
chair
we're there to get testimony we're here
we're here
to listen girls or giving testimony
right now ask questions but we don't
debate them
nor nor do we make our own home
that's very important
otherwise you wouldn't get people to
come in to testify
you have the public hearing because you
want to get that information
all right any other questions
you know what i would suggest is that
next week
when the lba comes in they're going to
go
through their package and into this
especially the new ones
all the all the kinds of documents
[Music]
the monthly focus the monthly
percentages of revenues
they'll go through the various
revenues the taxes and fees
and then after the lda does their thing
for about an hour the hour isn't just
quickly for them to talk
but for you to ask questions quote the
documents
will be given to you so you'll have
those
and then the department of revenue will
be
coming in to talk about an hour on their
revenues that they collect the revenues
they collect
is probably about 60
around 65 percent of the total revenues
not about
majority of the revenue because it's the
big ones
the uh business types of the interest in
dividend rules and loans tax
was that other taxes such as securities
liquor the lottery
[Music]
uh mr chairman there are six hands up
now
the first one was jenny camarlo and i
don't know the order of the others
oh okay mike i just have a request
um the literature that the uh
presenters at the economic update um
give us can we have that in color copy
because those charts are generally
color-coded
and i remember two years ago it was hard
to
read them afterwards without the color
that's a good point
again could you make sure
yeah we'll see about it
thank you well they don't all have to be
but maybe just the chart pages
[Music]
betas has their hand up yes um
mr chairman i'm finding it a little
difficult
to recognize some of the words you're
using i'm
i wonder if you can arrange your screen
so that you're looking more directly at
the camera
in my computer there's a little light
that shows where the camera
is and you so i adjust it so that i'm
looking straight into the camera
and most of the people participating in
this meeting
are looking straight forward and since
we're all going to be spending a lot of
time remotely
if you could uh think about making your
face directly looking at us is that
better
that's much better and it's just a minor
detail
uh at first i thought i was getting a
little deaf but it
i can turn up my sound on the computer
so apparently i've gotten used to
looking at people's mouths that
helps me understand what they're saying
so thank you very much thank you edith
next is jordan
yeah thank you norm i i just wanted for
the
freshman to remember that there's two
different sets of rules that the
we operate under the house normally
operates under
robert's rules for the committees but
the house itself
will operate some of the rules we passed
last week out in the parking lot
so i just it's just a subtle difference
as to
how the committee operates and how we
have a little more freedom to do some
things
that we can't do when we're sitting as a
body and
as representatives in reps hall just
you know fyi type stuff
yeah one one other thing uh regarding
the the color
of photos um you're absolutely correct
getting them but if
we get them sent to us you happen to
have a color printer
you can make your own it makes it easy
that way
saves the state money now if they would
only pay us a per diem for sitting on
our
butts in our houses that would be or
better
okay uh patrick
romney one
here i am um jordan i hate to i hate to
break the news to you
uh this is not why i had my hand raised
but uh we went to a chairs meeting on
friday
and the clerk clarified the issue of
robert's rules versus
mason and committees here's what he had
written down we do not follow robert's
rules anywhere in the new hampshire
house
house rules govern committee procedures
uh 100 to 111
we're silent masons to be consulted
so we have that that's uh um
a change when did he decide to do that
because we've been
doing that in our uh in the committee
for the last uh 20 years
i'm just i'm just a messenger on this
one
uh but but we're supposed to follow
masons all the way through
we do majors rules
and all these rules
alan
i have a few other things to mention
okay
especially for the freshmen uh you're
going to realize that we work very
closely with the department of revenue
administration
and the legislative budget assistance
that's dra and
lba those are the initials um
you're also going to find that we work
closely with the liquor commission and
the lottery commission
since we are the ones who deal with
tobacco gambling and liquor
issues so you're going to get to see a
lot of those folks as well
uh the pink card
i was mentioned they're still for the
former members and new members but
former members
they're still working on the process of
how a pink card if it's going to be
virtual
for the people testifying how do they
get their pink card in
and basically they are still in the
process of defining how that's going to
work
but basically when the calendar comes
out i think it's going to be that they
have to
email a certain person who will
put them on um there won't be a
physical pink card but it'll be a list
of people that want to testify from the
public
okay so that's that's still being worked
out
and same thing with the blue sheet for
people who want to sign in
for new members there's a sheet which
which
people who don't want to testify but
want to support the bill they to sign in
before a committee hearing
uh there'll be an electronic version of
the blue sheet as well
i just want to jump in norm just to make
sure everybody understands what an early
bill is
um because it's important to a couple of
committees like
like ways of means and finance we get a
lot of what they're called second
committee bills
so early bills or bills that go to a
a policy committee first like
commerce or or a municipal
and then they'll come to if it's a if it
has any
uh fee in there or any revenue that
needs to be generated
it will come to us as a second committee
and that happens like
in norm said after mid february we start
so when if we get 30 or 40 bills
uh this year as primary bills
remember we're also after after february
we're gonna have we're probably
in possession of another five to ten
bills in which we have to
uh act on as and just on the piece that
relates to fees and
and taxes uh that's that's our job
um the one thing about ways and means
not it's not true for every committee
uh but we try to actually fix bills and
that's where the subcommittee's come in
if we and and believe me we do a lot of
fixing of senate bills too
that come to us and they actually look
towards us to help fix them because we
actually
really spend time with these bills but
we do fix bills but the committee
generally we take the
temperature of the committee as to is
this bill
even if we fix it is this something we
think that the committee thinks is
worthy
of being fixed if yes then normal
call for a subcommittee to be formed to
work work work fix the bill
and uh and that usually requires
amendments etcetera etcetera
um the one
little thing that i i again flip through
from the
um the chairs meeting
i'll make sure everybody understands
this now this is really
important when we're physically in the
in the committee
is yes a prime sponsor after if you're a
prime sponsor in ways of means
you present your bill you can't come
back and sit down
and you cannot ask questions if if
you're a co-sponsor of a ways and means
bill
you're allowed to come and sit down back
in your seat
but you cannot ask questions so that's
that's the way that works and one end of
the thought i just wrote some notes down
is norm was talking
the lob when we get back to lob
currently the main entrance of the
legislative office building
is being repaired i just drove by there
over the weekend i went to the
audubon a little little all about hike
and concord and
this let me see how they're doing it
seems like there's still a lot of work
in that main entrance to be done so
that main entrance so if you ever try to
enter the lob you have to go around the
back
up the parking garage and there's a uh
there's a security guard there that will
will let you in
uh and because they're gonna have two
points of entry one in the llb as norm
said
because the security is gonna do a test
temperature test
on you uh and then let you in or you can
go through that side entrance which most
people some people especially freshmen
don't know where the store is
if you face the if you face the state
house if you look
go to your uh right from the main
entrance
and it's a basement entrance on the side
entrance of uh
uh there and that that's uh there's
always a state trooper that
uh there's a state trooper station there
that
uh they'll they'll test you et cetera
so those are my comments uh just chat
john notes as normal talking
thank you yeah all these issues
are highlighted on
those three sheets that i provided you
on the organization day
so i would go through each and every one
of them
um alan
you're next thank you mr chair
um i i just want to call to everyone's
attention that
we are graced by the presence of the
honorable
jerry stringham he's an esteemed alumni
of
the ways and means committee and he's
watching us as we speak now
so i just wanted to acknowledge him and
i hope he's not a stranger to this
committee
discussion uh representative stringham
often
had very insightful uh and helpful
comments regarding uh those we were
looking at and i just want to say hi
jerry we already miss you
yes well thank you for those fine words
um
susan
you know you have done mute susan
i do uh i've got two things here one of
them
is from something that representative
brownie said
on i've been wondering are they going to
give us parking assignments before
next week or do we just
all go down to the the garage
on storm street
i i would think that you'd have those
parking assignments
coming out
the other thing though was on when we're
doing a hearing
quite very frequently somebody comes to
the hearing with the intention of
listening and speaking if necessary
and if they have to sign up ahead of
time
i guess a whole lot of people are going
to have to sign up that might then want
to waive it
that could very well be the um
as pat said the process
for the pink cards and the blue sheets
have not been
uh generated yet because how do you do
it
they haven't come up with a solution yet
so that's been worked on
and they won't let us know norm can i
jump in
yeah you're right norma i the we at the
chairs meeting we asked a lot of
questions uh there were a lot of
unanswered questions
uh these are some of them how's that all
going to work
and the more you ask the questions the
more you know so they're working on it
the final rule isn't out yet as to how
we're going to do this
but i would imagine that uh that's why
we that's why we're going to have
the other thing is that normally you may
want to spend one minute one more minute
again
on requesting the uh technical people
for the committee
that we're looking for too you may want
to explain that a little bit more
why we need that uh well
the problem is right now you have we
have jennifer for
who's who's
monitoring the meeting when we get to
committees
if you don't mind them if if we get to
committees it's very hard for the chair
to monitor what's going on
with people from the outside et cetera
et cetera
it's hard for the clerk to do that as
well so the solution is only there's
only four researchers
it's it's impossible to spread them
across all these meetings so
the solution is to have a couple of
people
on our committee each of the committees
be
volunteers to monitor
when we're back to hybrid when we're
back to actually being
in the double rooms but the public is
calling in
that uh that we have a couple of our
members who are one at a time though
willing to
for that that day to monitor uh
what's going on the what's online so
norm you want to take it from there but
that that's
that's the reason for that that that was
the solution to
not enough staff to cover potentially
eight
potentially eight hearings going on at
the same time
we just don't have enough researchers to
cover that
and we'll be getting into that
representative ames
yeah i'm sorry i was slow with that um
yeah just
a question that uh it goes back to
deadlines and uh you mentioned
norm that uh you know the first deadline
we'll be bumping into is february 18th
and that's not far away
um plus the budget uh message from the
governor will be coming over on the
16th i think
[Music]
and so that brought to mind the fact
that we now
have in rule as a result of the
recent meeting in session of the house a
allowance a provision that allows the
uh uh extension change of those
of those time deadlines that are in the
rules uh by the speaker after
consultation
and i wondered if there's been any
discussion of that
we obviously are this whole system that
we're working with is not only new but
it's awkward and
difficult and and while
some things probably just can't change
because
of the budget and it's sort of absolute
deadline
at the end of june
i wondered whether there's been any
discussion of what can be done
to make this all manageable
there has been some discussion and it's
a
discussion in part and progress because
we don't know what the
answers are and we're not sure what the
questions
the governor's budget on the 15th
normally
looks like it may be this the 16th
the 16th we want to have our run is
and the 18th is the second committed
bills
that have to be out of the committee at
that point in time
depends on how many second committee
bills we have now whether or not
that's going to be a real issue for us
and
i hope that very soon i'll know
all the bills that we have and having a
second committee
if it's just one or two second committee
deals we should be able to
hold it because the 18th
is five weeks away
the next week you know what we're going
to be going next week
you know we're going to be doing the
week after this and that takes care of
two weeks
it's three weeks left and then
we still need to have a work session
on revenues that's the most important
thing we have right now that's number
one priority
now if i find that
we have too many second committee bills
that we're gonna have to come to some
agreement with the speaker
and say hey you can't do this you may
say
well okay what we'll do is just
retaining these bills
and that could be one solution but then
if there's something that they're
experiencing important goals
[Music]
we need to know what we have to deal
with we don't know that yet
but you're right it's a good work in
progress it's going to be challenges
all the way up all the way along
because we can't if we could
we have problems and we can meet
as a committee as a whole meeting the
schedules that we have
now multiplying what the problems are
and you can't
meet as a whole to discuss these things
and to interrogate
witnesses and all that in person
it's a whole different world we have to
work
thank you and if anybody has any
suggestions
please step right up to the plate
and as far as uh this new world of
being able to operate under the zoom and
and i did
if you have experience that you think
you can help
let me know because we're gonna need you
to make the committee successful
there's 24 of us and
whoever's running a meeting
can't handle everything all at once it
has to concentrate on the meeting itself
so we need what happens
okay uh susan your hand is still up
um yeah well i've been putting it up and
taking it down as you did things
but uh i just wanted to volunteer
on some of us that have been through
this quite a lot
and so we don't have to listen quite as
attentively to the testimony as others
maybe could help by just watching the
the uh hand raising
or or something
yes especially when we're talking as a
committee
right and and not only the hand raising
from
the participants but we need to
be able to monitor the public
and that may take two two people one for
monitoring the participants and one for
mourning the public
we need to treat them as well as we
treat ourselves
i'm not sure does the public have
on a hand raising facility i don't
see it i'm not sure i'm looking at the
attendees list
they do have it's just that no one in
the attendees
should be raising their hand right now
ah right
they okay again
how do they get questions to us
or comments um
if you were soliciting comments during a
work session um
you could ask anyone who
you could you could call on someone
specifically that you could see in the
attendee list
or you could ask an attendee to raise
their hand yeah
and and i think it all boils down to
how do we replicate
the blue sheet i think those
instructions
are becoming representative major from
um
from leadership right and that that has
come yet yes the same way is how do we
replicate the
pink parts that hasn't been solved yet
i've said major if i could i can't
remember if you
in explained who gen 4 is
yes she did okay our researcher not just
a staffer who's very good at tech jen
is a committed researcher and she's one
of the best there is
at the lld and then our committee
assistant is karen
koloski and
thank you she's
she's good um
but both the committee researcher and
the committee
assistance not only serve
our committees our committee but a
number of other committees
i think again how many committees do you
serve
um i have three permanent committees
weights and means
education and judiciary um
our beloved joel anderson retired at the
end of the year
after i believe 33 years of service um
and so i'm i'm currently also filling in
for fish and game and science and tech
wow and and karen is
just almost the same
yes yes joel anderson
was a committee assistant when i was on
science and technology back in 1997.
he's retired now
now representative all
yes um first i'd like to offer my
services
to help in any way i'm relatively tech
savvy
great and second i
wondered if the freshmen know how to
access the bills
um through the general court website so
you can start looking at them
and if not maybe
we could tell them now or jen could send
them a little
outline of how to get there
all right i
maybe i'm wrong but i assume that they
have been attending the freshman
workshops is there any freshman here
doesn't know how to access the bills
yeah you go
i was just going to say you go to the
committees and
the ways and means and then it says
bills
uh
it's just there sorry
listen committee yeah so if you go
through the
committee our ways and means committee
you'll
you'll find a way to see all the bills
and then you just click on the number
and it will pop up
and you can open it or read it
representative would you mind
if any of the freshmen
how many members have a problem with
doing this
if they contact you and you walk them
through this
that'd be fine yeah sure i don't mind
that would be simpler because if you get
a head start on them
when we finally get rolling you'll it's
a
it's helpful right because that
and that's from experience you you want
to go through
and read every bill as soon as you
can and start making notes on it
so that you're not reading the bill when
the public hearing comes up you want to
read the bill ahead of time make
notes so you know what your questions
are going to be
and you may want to ask some questions
before we even had the public hearing so
you understand better
what's going on and then
as a result the committee is a better
committee
because of
back to that question about uh who's
going to enable the
or uh people who want to testify to
speak
on zoom uh my understanding is that once
they sign up in the as a
that they want to speak before the night
before day before
the hearing uh once it once it's
published in the calendar
the calendar they can start saying they
want to speak to the bill
that somehow magically i don't know if
it's going to be centralized or
decentralized
but then they they'll be able they will
be enabled
to uh enter the meeting in a way that
they can be recognized
that's all we know so far yeah but we
don't know
the detail of that
thank you uh any more
questions
not seeing any more questions and
i will notify you about next week
whether it's going to be a completely
zone meeting
but it's going to you're going to be
meeting in
reps hall i'll also get the schedule out
once i get the okay from the speaker's
office what days we can have the
following week
to meet with all the agency heads
associated with
all the revenue streams so we can get
that under our belt
and then work towards the following and
next week
to start doing the work sessions on the
revenues
i just as soon as
we have all the bills then i'll know
what the early bills are
and see whether or not we can handle
those as well as the revenue estimates
within the time frame that's been
allotted to us
and then see what what our next step
would be
so so listen you have anything else
uh
so basically i just had a question on
scheduling i know that you said that
because of
the constraints with zoom and so forth
in meeting rooms
um meetings could be scheduled anywhere
from monday to friday
um with the goal i mean and i know
typically when i have other things to
schedule i usually try to schedule
them on mondays or friday to avoid
conflicts
with the goal be to try to schedule
things between tuesday and thursday and
then monday and friday would be
back up
try to get all of our committee work
tuesday wednesday and thursday
so that we can do our other stuff
on mondays and fridays such as
and i'll i'll try to do that and just as
soon as i find out
what they're going to a lot to us i'll
let you everybody do um
all right okay there's one more
uh walter spellsbury
thank you mr chairman i suppose this
asks for a broad generalization but more
or less
what might we be expecting to receive in
hard copy
as this process follows and what
should we anticipate in terms of running
the printing press at home good
question excellent question jen
um i i don't think we have an answer for
this yet
it's another one of those things that um
that we're waiting for a final word but
i'll certainly keep it in mind and if i
learn something i can
i can pass that along what we're trying
to do
is get from the
presenters early enough a
copy so that we can copy it and send it
out to you
but obviously if they send it to us on
friday
that that won't that will not happen i
can assure you that for the
presentations next week that's not going
to be an option
to to to send it through the mail
because they um
they most likely won't get their
materials to me by
until thursday and then monday is a
holiday
right all of the materials for next
week's
program will be posted online
and if there's any problem accessing
them that way i can
i can email them to you as well but i
i can tell you for sure for next week's
programs that's not going to be
something that we'll be able to do to
mail them
we're still getting christmas cards
mailed the 14th of december
i got one yesterday the 14th of december
well i'm sure the zoom environment is
changing things
and none of us knows exactly what to
expect but
um are bills generally printed and
distributed or is that also something
that we just read online and print off
on our own
um if you have access to net into the
state house
you can go up to the sagittarian alarms
or the collects office and get copies of
the bills
but they're not normally distributed
normally if when you do your business at
the state house
uh the your committee assistant
will have all the bills for your
committee
in your slot so they're there
now where we don't go to this llv or the
state house
then if we want to know about the bills
we're going to have to print them
ourselves
or take a trip up to the state house
and get a coffee from the collector
office
so i've been doing a lot of printing
matter of fact
i'm wearing my printer out
in on ways of means
you have to work with printed copies
you i go through
almost a thousand pages a month
i'm not kidding
because this is the beginning of a
session you've got to print
all this stuff
most of the presentations that are
coming out for next week
i'll probably end up printing most of it
because jen says they're not going to
send it to us so that we have it
so she has it monday when you can send
it out even if you do send it out we may
not get it
so i would advise getting it pointed
because
if you have a pretty copy you're a lot
better off you can make notes on that
print copy as your presenters
talking about it so
i'll always err on this either printing
there
now it's expensive
there's a better answer than that
susan
sorry uh first on we have one person on
our committee
who uh has no computer that's
representative griffin and i hope that
someone's going to get her
the materials for next week somehow
printed on and
second on is it going to be at all
possible maybe for
the clerk's office to create bundles
of bills by committee and
enough for each committee and have those
of us that can
drive into concord to pick them up
no way because they aren't going to want
us in the building all the time
going in to try to go to the clerk's
office and they're
not going to want that
um let me talk to the clerk about
about that and we'll send an email to it
to all the committee members what that
process will do
yeah on the same topic i think it's only
fair that
we you and i should really uh talk to
the speaker about this one
you know that we're going to be saving a
lot of mileage money
so i i i don't think it should be a
burden on the
on our legislative budget to have
all of the bills mailed to us ahead of
time i think that's only fair
i mean um i've been
the last year i've been spending a lot
of money on my own paper on my own ink
it's not cheap and i don't think it's
i think it's unreasonable for them to
ask our members to print all the stuff
that comes to us
the other concern i got as we've been
talking here is
those of us been around we know that
everybody who testifies
comes in with some handouts or multiple
handouts
and the question becomes how are we
going to get all those handouts
and those handouts are very helpful they
have charts and things that you can
relate to that they
point to as they're testifying and i
think it's unreasonable
to ask uh
again for us to up to for all the
committee members to
to print these out at home uh we all
have different quality printers and all
of that
so this is a big issue i think uh i
don't i don't think it's a fiscal issue
because we're saving all the money on
mileage i think it's a matter of
just it's a timing issue of how quickly
things can get to us in the mail
the bills certainly should begin we
should get the bills in in the mail
uh well ahead of time uh so we don't
have to print those
uh and you should have paper copies
because we all re we all write on those
things
uh everybody that i know we write our
notes on the bills
uh and keep track especially then when
we go to executive session we remind
ourselves of what was said and
and what's there so but anyway i think
that's something that's
that's fair that we should try to work
on um and uh
you and i know i could talk offline on
this but thank you
representative salsa
tom
thank you um i was just going to say i
know
already bills are moving forward all of
these comments
make me think the more we could put off
until next year the better when we get
more back to a normal
uh committee setup because uh
it just seems like to prioritize the
most important bills
the most important handouts you know and
so on it's going to be very important
i'm with you tom
represent elmer
thank you on i just want to speak up
for the people in the 037 zip code
which i think is four of us including
the gentleman from charleston i think
it's 0.37
anything that comes from concord in
normal times
takes three to four working days to
arrive
on so on i don't know if you could speak
to the clerk or maybe i should speak to
the clerk if this happens
on that on somebody
from his uh from the staff
who's driving up past new london
can dump things in a post office
in that direction so that we don't have
to wait
probably at this point two weeks for
things to show up
if it's going to go by mail
or maybe we just end up spending a lot
of money on print
thanks well i think people are going to
have to
come up with some workarounds i know i
have uh
my hp instant ink with
a helix package it started at 15
a month then in 1999 a month
now 25 40 20
24.99 a month that gives me 700 pages
and then every 150 more it's
pages and so much it's costing me at
bundles
i think we're uh have we finished our
meeting really
okay i i think you probably have
everybody's satisfied then
we will let you know about the status of
next week's
two days of economic updates and how
we're going to handle those
i'll find out how
we can get these bills to you and
anything else we'll communicate to you
there's one one final thing we're
operating on a legislative
license right now and there's only so
many
legislative licenses that can
be handled at once
does anybody have a problem uh
i have my own license for the zoom
so if i can't have a legislative license
time slot does anybody have a problem if
we need to have a
special meeting with them
mr chairman i don't know what the
current speaker
uh wants to do about this but
we were forbidden from meeting
on private zooms for a public meeting
last term
which as you know caused all kinds of
workarounds
we did a lot of meeting in separate
caucuses
and then got together and exchanged
information and then finally could hold
a public meeting
to bring out what we'd all been working
on
so we're going to have to figure out a
work
okay um nobody else has anything else to
contribute then
i thank everybody for joining the
meeting today
and we'll see you next week
thank you thank you mr chuck
bye